tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
sono fa vj oggi siamo grati perché stavo
dicendo super meat boy siamo altro dati
su happy days e non mi fate strane idee
che quella merda di super meat boy
riapro manco se mi chiedono in cinetv
anni già praga si facciamo il primo
perché ancora non mi sono ripreso dall
ultimo episodio di neanche lui si è
ripreso dall ultimo episodio che bella
faccia ascolta zio di saltare più in
alto
ok però sempre un po più lungo se no
sarà un cazzo ragazzi non ci è
impossibile il suo livello sono sei
ragazzi il nuovo superman
ho trovato in lui
è morto era lui è come superman
bellissimo cazzo che solo questo merito
al pollice in su ragazzi non ho parole
rock swing farm facciamo nel senso che
un porno anno devo cerchio bello il buco
e lì cioè noto voglio dire bravo lo zio
complimenti per la mia fosse ci arrivo
no ci ho sperato però ci ho sperato fino
all'ultimo ma se sono eurhop swing
arcobaleno e perché sono proprio i
matrimoni gay
non lo so però è di è morto a ragazzi
deve entrarci di culo se non c'entro
matthew madonna c'è basta basta però se
scrivo però che cosa succede
eccolo qui perfetto che mi dà grazie zia
b però non c'era bisogno
singh tra facciamo un altro rob simmons
e c'era quello eva basta che ho capito
che il gay che ci sono matrimoni gay
però basta e che cazzo lo metto anche la
webcam la metto così ragazzi perfetto è
una roba è giusto così ci siamo ci siamo
ma che bel salto più complimenti ma dove
l'hai vista la vittoria di produce sei
cieco poco fighter mlg e la madonna
cos'è ma c'è anche snoop dogg ancora ma
basta cos'è sono tutti così sti livelli
ultimamente ma che cazzo me ne frega
disco stavo scherzando snoop doggy è
sempre snoop dogg tensione ragazzi mossa
diversi incappanda rey mysterio sarebbe
fiero a valence
ormai c'è sempre la la valanga lav in
agenda il frame ho capito tutto parte
cinque secondi porca [ __ ] passa dal
tedesco dall'inglese lebherz trend
rennes francia cazzo luke potevi dirmelo
appello le zio bob che ci fai lì sotto
si sorpassa bravissime 2 vaden tua madre
vale bocchino è bravo già fatta e stato
bello e i complimenti devenyns bel brand
strange and ivf rey aveva tentato di
scrivere fa vigenti forse ce l'ha
scritto e meteore varia dai [ __ ]
però non ne sono sicuro ragazzi
va beh ok ho mica finalmente se tnt
della mia se usciti di burt è bravo luke
cazzo fa e va bene tutto sugli alberi e
ragazzi sono un vandalo sono un vandalo
sono sandalo anche cosa ci fanno non c'è
chi li no no no che partita
no non ci credo che vuoi salire sul
camion ci sono riuscito ragazzi ci
credete
dai dai che arriva la moneta
ovvio che scavalco bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye zio menzio la moneta non ci
credo mai perché manca un millimetro
fratello affanculo mi chiama 220 secondi
per forza callata è stato un parto però
ce l'abbiamo fatta
l'importante queste ragazze frasi troppo
5 anno questo bellissimo con un'altra
volta devo coprire il buco
adesso sono salvo ragazzi credetemi che
sono salvo perfetto non sono mica morto
che parata oddio come ho fatto bene va
bene
sette secondi perché 7 la misura massima
di qualsiasi cosa ragazza anche della
pro reggina e tu demonte in due sopra le
montagne a caso con l'oncia che cosa fai
nonno perché cerchi nell'immondizia
perché quel tizio si sta infilando una
bottiglia nel di ketchup nelle natiche
fatemi capire o una casa quando avrai
pulito la tua stanza miglia quanto la
stimo soprano al dato un calcio agli
occhi bravo zio caputa questo volando
cazzo è meglio dt ragazzi è la madonna
che montagna complimenti è stata la
città più bella del secolo ha rimediato
un pezzo di vetro nel nell'esofago
proprio poetico e meraviglioso ragazzi
presi basso rampage madonna che seguendo
questo mi fa paura le cave lo dico pelle
smartphone stay on job ai giangia e
[ __ ] della patata devo guidare
questo bus pieno di ragazzini e via
ragazzi forza ad insegna zio fabia
guidare prima cosa si tiene la testa
fuori dal parabrezza e poi tutto il culo
fuori da parabrezza e questo è il modo
più sicuro per guidare i ragazzi poi e
poi si esplode
ma si continua a virare ragazzi perché
se esplodente e non dovete lasciarvi
intimorire dalla gente ok dovete
continuare a guidare anche se babbo
natale vi offre della birra dovete
continuare a guidare
effetto crisi elementari bel livello
ragazzi complimenti su word proprio
music musica immenso justin bieber che
bella merda ci siamo ragazzi però come
parlano tutti al ritmo di bei ragazzi
guardate la tizia obesa come balla che
ha vinto tutto è obesa non c'è una spada
che cazzo faccio ti uccido me ne sbatto
il cazzo e io lo so che ho sbagliato ma
ha la tizia un premier spuntato e siamo
su happy with happy with the place è più
ma che cazzo porca [ __ ]
ma non ci credo ma come cazzo non riesco
a prendere comics sono justin bieber che
mi non sbagliare no lega non è possibile
ecco è morto
roma la tizia un pene spuntato ma perché
basta [ __ ] sapere perché quello balla
con quattro spade mila minchia eseguire
al meglio ma basta e crepa parata
paparazzata a tampa rapa paki paki ea
seguire on next non è morto un cazzo di
in nessuno guarda come ma l'acqua e
micro nell'assoluta rata da un rapporto
a tampa arafat amp amp amp amp anta
rampa mamma che è fatta di ragazzi non
mi sta bene sua canzone mentali piovono
le spade addosso
ciao frate bravo adesso balla così
inculati l'aria ilaria inculati l'aria
nola e l'apostrofo aria ho detto ho
vinto basta dai che cazzo sì mi sono
effetti gioco d'insieme
[Musica]
ragazzi io adoro ep risponde così non lo
so perché mi piace eto'o sono un
deficiente ma mi piace tanto il race
sono questa che ancora non ho fatto una
gara con le macchine considera ecco così
che si guida regala quindi al mio
autista di fiducia è un figo
ditemi voi se l'avete mai vista una
persona a guidare meglio di sto tizio ma
neanche in vin diesel in fast and
furious ma le ragazze tutti noi cazzo
[Musica]
ragazzi ma perché sto guidando col culo
ma non è possibile mai nella vita
sentite non ce la fai a fare un ok bravo
bravo che drift drift il trick che ci
abbia nonché fisica la macchina può
falsa
ho parcheggiato ceo parcheggio così rega
posto perfetto
grazie mille non lo so che sa guidare
bene col culo però è una dote che in
pochi hanno poveri ragazzi facciamo un
paio di miei livelli visto che siamo
arrivati tipo alla fine fa vj sfigato
allora innanzitutto tua madre vabbè
avanti cos'è cosa devo fare
il bello di un livello che ispira
cos'era 11 ciak quello era un pezzo di
non è un livello che trasuda propaggine
5 stelle zio complimenti proprio mi ha
cambiato la giornata da così a così fa
dj quiz
ragazzi io ho paura ho veramente paura
di vedere che cazzo come si chiama fa vj
lorenzo marco non mi chiama lorenzo
puntini puntini zio mi spiace mi chiamo
lorenzo e basta scritto proprio lorenzo
e basta qual era il primo video di fa vj
è più il lander man's land giusto lo so
fare il mio quiz come si chiama il
personaggio che stai usando ora scimmia
si chiama è di odio l'hai scritto giusto
non ci credo mai che ha scritto giusto
ed il fantastico premi z se lo avessi
mal di schiena non ci credo ma va bene
premiamo sto cazzo di z no ho sbagliato
non ho premuto z ma me ne sbatto posso
essere trattato che sono entrati grazie
zio mi hai fatto sentire una persona
trasgressiva fa vj forever creato da
faccio after che cazzo nicchia frate
faccio after parafa bello del livello
faccia ma si vede che sei in after
quando fai le cose o mio dio ho vinto
credo che sia stato il livello più
intelligente che io abbia mai giocato in
tutta la mia vita più intelligente di
sto tizio qui
d'accordo ragazzi ray che possono un
episodio spero che ho visto vi sia
piaciuto un mi piace
secondo voi se si è fatto di canne
mentre andava in after sto tizio dato ha
preso anche cinque stelle ma sono
drogati pure quelli che han giocato sto
livello per ragazzi lasciamo perdere
comunque spero che vi sia piaciuto cosa
sei tu sei video è piaciuta tanto mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
mai la tratta nella descrizione solo se
dovessi discreta ci vediamo al prossimo
video è la ragazza
[Musica]